[Musica]
alcuni credono che quello che scrivono
in internet non abbia influenza sulla
loro vita o sulla vita dei loro
interlocutori più o meno dieci anni fa
io sono entrato in un forum e ho
cominciato a scrivere quello che
scrivevano il forum mi ha fatto aprire
un blog perché mi dicevano che ero bravo
a scrivere quello che scrivevano ai blog
mi ha fatto chiamare da giornalisti per
scrivere per una testata e poi per delle
riviste
alla fine è diventato il mio lavoro è
diventata la mia carriera io scrivo
questo il mio lavoro
dieci anni fa ho iniziato cinque anni fa
io sto perdendo la casa della mia
famiglia nonché l'unica casa che ho per
qualcosa che ho scritto in internet le
cause legali costano e io scrivendo sono
sicuro che l'avete sentito dire a chi
scrive non vive bene e io voglio
difenderla con la casa perché ci sono
cresciuto per difendere la casa dove sei
cresciuto fi qualunque cosa io prendo
qualunque tipo di lavoro mi arrivi vengo
contattato da una testata nazionale
molto importante che mi chiede di curare
una rubrica la rubrica di cronaca nera
la cronaca nera e un argomento difficile
ma a me va bene e va bene qualsiasi cosa
ho bisogno di soldi mi chiedono di
tenere una rubrica che però racconti la
cronaca nera in maniera pulp in maniera
grottesca in maniera farsesca distorta
perché perché è quello che tira è quello
che fa sensazione
ragazzi io lo faccio fra immediatamente
nel ferragosto del 2014 in america una
pornodiva viene aggredita e violentata
dal suo ex marito un lottatore di mma ci
devo scrivere un pezzo
io parto da questo ragionamento
la stragrande maggioranza di noi non
conosce davvero la violenza noi non
siamo persone violente e mi auguro che
nessuno qui dentro si è mai stato
violentato
quindi la cronaca nera a una dialettica
molto precisa per cui nomi la leggiamo
ci indigniamo e poi voltiamo pagina
la mia idea è questa io ti racconto
questo fatto visto con gli occhi di una
persona violenta e viene fornito
articolo molto forte molto emotivo e
l'emotività ci rende irrazionali una
persona legge l'articolo non lo capisce
va dai suoi followers e dice che io
incito la violenza sulle donne
all'improvviso la bacheca di questa
testata si riempie di commenti che
chiedono il mio licenziamento
la rimozione dell'articolo e
innumerevoli minacce era ferragosto la
testata prende paura rimuove subito
l'articolo ma questo non ferma i
commenti
anzi se io per quella querela
ve la ricordate non avessi già blindato
i miei social su twitter
c'erano persone che si coordinavano nei
giorni successivi per sapere chi ero
dove abitavo chi erano i miei amici
volevano sapere chi era la mia donna
tutto per un articolo che non potevano
aver letto perché era stato rimosso
alla fine io perdo il lavoro perché la
casa dei miei genitori
e mentre mentre esco per l'ultima volta
me lo ricordo chiaramente mentre esco da
questa casa dico ma per chi e chi perché
questo è il web mi rispondono il web il
web dove abita il web oggi lo diamo per
scontato
l'abbiamo sentito tutti il web si
indigna il web insorge il web condanna
il web si commuove il massimo opinion
leader
oggi è il web e nessuno di noi ha la più
pallida idea di chi sia il web
penso all'epoca abbiamo un conto in
sospeso però io ti trovo così mi metto a
studiarlo a studiare il web a cercare di
capire chi è come funziona
e nel corso del tempo nel corso degli
anni
vedo che a decine di persone succedono
la stessa cosa che è successa a me e
comincio a vedere dei pattern che in
psicologia si chiamano pattern
comportamentale
il web si comporta nello stesso modo
come se fosse davvero una persona è un
certo punto li trovo ritrovo scritti
ritrovo elencati il web è impulsivo e
irritabile il web suggestionabile e
credulone
il web è esagerato e semplicistico il
web e autoritario intollerante
conservatore il web è capace di enormi
atti di altruismo e altrettanti di
crudeltà
sono sicuro che oggi nel 2019 tutti voi
leggendo questi pattern di tesi è la
classica folla di internet ed è giusto
perché questa roba non l'ho scritta io
la scritta un sociologo di nome gustave
le bon e 1890 cent'anni prima che
internet fosse anche solo remotamente
diffuso ma usato un altro termine non ha
usato il web ha usato un'altra parola
crude folla perché il web non esiste la
parola web è una cosa che ci siamo
creati per giustificare e depotenziare
una cosa enorme che è la folla non
esistono followers non esistono haters
non esistono social esiste solo ed
esclusivamente la folla freud 1921 un
insieme di individui diversi sottoposti
a un forte impulso emotivo possono
assumere i conti le caratteristiche di
una folla psicologica perché la folla
non è mai la somma delle intelligenze
che la compongono
viceversa la sua regressione e puro
istinto vedete noi
a me piace la storia noi in realtà siamo
sempre gli stessi gli stessi di 10.000
anni fa i nostri istinti quelli di cui
hanno parlato nell'altro talk i nostri
istinti la nostra esiste immaginatevela
come se fosse acqua
noi come persone la nostra personalità è
un acquario è composta da quattro pareti
e queste pareti sono di vetro sono molto
fra
sono l'empatia che abbiamo verso il
prossimo
sono l'educazione che abbiamo ricevuto
quando eravamo piccolissimi e
soprattutto la consapevolezza delle
conseguenze delle nostre azioni e del
giudizio degli altri
questa è la nostra personalità maslow
nel 1952 fece una piramide dei bisogni
per dire quali sono i bisogni
dell'essere umano nei primi due livelli
ci sono sopravvivenza e sicurezza
quelli più facili ho fame o freddo o
sonno ho paura che mi incidano sono
quelli semplici ma subito sopra il
bisogno più forte dell'essere umano è il
bisogno di appartenenza e il bisogno di
sentirsi parte di qualcosa di una tribù
di un gruppo di di una nazione di una
città di un'elite noi abbiamo bisogno di
appartenere a qualcosa
quando noi prendiamo tutte queste
persone e le scontriamo insieme le
pareti crollano l'acqua defluisce elici
amalgamiamo regredendo diventando puro
istinto diventando animali irrazionali
non importa chi è presente all'interno
di quella folla si comporterà sempre
nello stesso modo come era contro la
bibbia quando liberano barabba o quando
ci fu il per il periodo del
dell'ostracismo la folla si comporta
nello stesso identico modo
e fare parte della folla è una cosa
enorme che poi dite mi riguarda ma
essere una folla è come avere è come
avere la forza di hulk e
contemporaneamente il mantello
dell'invisibilità di harry potter
possiamo fare tutto possiamo colpire
chiunque e nessuno pagherà mai perché
nella folla
in realtà non c'è nessuno abbiamo esempi
li vediamo tutti i giorni prendete
quando qualcuno scrisse in internet
insulti e minacce di morte al nostro
presidente della repubblica ha poi
giornalisti andarono a prenderlo e lui
cosa disse
ho scritto una minchiata
vi chiedo scusa andarono a prendere aida
yespica le iene le chiesero di
incontrare il suo iter al suo iter era
uno studente e lei disse ma perché mi
insulti perché vorresti uccidermi e lui
disse ma non lo so io
mentre lo scrivevo mi sembrava
divertente ti chiedo scusa
vittorio sgarbi sempre lei ha né il suo
iter un prete un uomo di grande cultura
e quando non mi sono di fronte a quello
che aveva scritto lui prima nega poi
dimostrarono gli screenshot lui chiedo
scusa
non ero me stesso non ero me stesso è
una definizione bellissima se ci pensate
ed è molto accurata
perché è vera voi all'interno della
folla non siete voi stessi ma la folla
per esistere ha bisogno di una cosa ed è
un bersaglio la folla non può esistere
senza un bersaglio perché il bersaglio
ci definisce per contrasto il bersaglio
è la differenza tra io e te e noi contro
di lui senza di lui non abbiamo una
folla
ci serve un bersaglio perché distruggere
è la cosa che ci piace di più
all'istinto più basico pensate pensate i
bambini di 4 anni che hanno l'istinto a
distruggere i castelli di sabbia
pensate alla scimmia di odissea nello
spazio con l'osso distruggere un istinto
basico costruire
costruire no perché costruire difficile
richiede coordinazione collaborazione
pianificazione ragionamento tutte cose
che la folla non è in grado di fare la
folla ha bisogno di un bersaglio ma non
è in grado di procurarselo cosa fa fare
un patto col diavolo ha bisogno di
qualcuno che glielo fornisca ed è così
che nasce la figura del capo popolo così
famosa nella storia
oggi però hanno un altro nome
naturalmente oggi si chiamano web star
influencer opinion leader account molto
rispettati che delegano a cui noi folla
e le chiama il compito di scegliere il
bersaglio e loro in cambio se lo
forniscono questo è un uomo che incita
la violenza sulle donne non serve che
leggi l'articolo te lo dico io
garantisco io ragiono io in cambio tu mi
dai la tua forza
mi dai tuoi numeri e da il tuo like e
questo mi da celebrità
questo è un capopopolo è una persona che
ci fornisce un bersaglio e quando noi
colpiamo qualcuno non siamo davvero
responsabili siamo responsabili come un
fiocco di neve sarebbe responsabile di
una valanga si c'eravamo dormiamo
tranquilli perché lo facevano tutti le
conseguenze di tutto questo potete
immaginarvi le una persona da un momento
all'altro può diventare un capopopolo
dicendo guarda guarda cosa ha detto
questo è una vergogna è vero o no con
dvd insultano anche tu diventa folla
arti la tua umanità perdi la tua
singolarità regredisce perché perché
distruggere è bello perché distruggere
ci fa sentire appartenenti a qualcosa
il punto è che è qui che voi potete
fregarli la folla è invincibile la folla
immortale ma una cosa che nessuno
apparentemente pronuncia più ed è che
voi in realtà avete il controllo voi
siete perseguitati dalla folla la folla
con questo vi chiama giorno e notte i
vostri amici i vostri parenti guarda
cosa ha detto questo condividi questo ma
non ti fa schifo ma non gli vuoi dire
qualcosa scrivi questo ci perseguita se
non ci dimentichiamo il portafogli a
casa lo lasciamo ma questo no
abbiamo bisogno della forza della folla
della sua invisibilità ma noi voi potete
scegliere di non dargli questo potere
con un gesto molto semplice silenziati
capipopolo e li avete tutti in bacheca
sono sicuro che ognuno di voi in questo
momento sta pensando a un account che
gli dice guarda cosa ha detto questo non
è una vergogna alcuni scrivono ad altri
account farlo lo screenshot e ve lo
mostrano perché perché vogliono
disperatamente la vostra forza
evitate i capipopolo evitate soprattutto
gli aspiranti capipopolo quelli che vi
dicono aiutami a fare del male a
qualcuno
tutti quelli che vi chiedono invece di
dare perché li riconoscete così persone
che forniscono dei contenuti e persone
che invece ne richiedono persone che
deridono invece di ridere persone che
non fanno altro che chiedere distruzione
silenziate lì e allora diventerebbe
davvero un élite scoprirete di avere a
disposizione la cosa più potente che sia
mai stata inventata che a internet è in
grado di metterci in contatto con uomini
da ogni parte del mondo
mi ha fatto accedere a documenti che
sono in biblioteche russe tutto questo
perché io ho scelto di evitare sia i
capipopolo che di voler diventare un
capopopolo
togliete questo voi avrete un internet
che nessuno nessuno oggi se non una
ristrettissima cerchia a
a quel punto non solo sarà il terribili
ma riuscirete imparare a resistere
all'impulso all'istinto perché è proprio
questo che alla fine vi farà una
carriera e soprattutto vi eleverà dalla
bestia all'essere umano grazie
[Applauso]